I see this life like a swinging vine,...
...swing my heart across the line.
In my face is flashing signs.
"Seek it out and ye shall find."
Old, but I'm not that old.
Young, but I'm not that bold.
And I don't think the world is sold...
...on just doing what we're told.
I feel something so right...
...doing the wrong thing.
I feel something so wrong...
...doing the right thing.
I couldn't lie, couldn't lie, couldn't lie.
Everything that kills me makes me feel alive.
Lately, I've been, I've been losing sleep,...
...dreaming about the things that we could be.
And baby, I've been, I've been praying hard,...
...said no more counting dollars,...
...we'll be counting stars.
Lately, I've been, I've been losing sleep,...
...dreaming about the things that we could be.
And baby, I've been, I've been praying hard,...
...said no more counting dollars,...
...we'll be counting, we'll be counting stars.